le chers collègues pour la dernière
réunion notre commission avant le
renouvellement du Sénat à la suite des
élections nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir cet après-midi les ministres
Bruno Le Maire et Thomas Cazenave qui
viennent nous présenter le projet de loi
de finance pour 2024 délibéré ce matin
en Conseil des ministres
si bien sûr Monsieur le Maire connait
très bien notre commission c'est la
première fois que nous recevons monsieur
cazena en tant que ministre délégué
chargé du budget et je lui adresse donc
la bienvenue parmi nous en votre nom
peut-être
est-il utile de rappeler que c'est bien
sur le budget 2024 que porte notre
réunion et non sur le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques sur
lequel l'audition du président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques portait
également ce matin puisque le Haut
Conseil rendu son avis sur la
trajectoire révisée des finances
publiques que propose le gouvernement en
nouvelle lecture de ce texte
les sujets sont toutefois liés puisque
ce budget s'inscrit dans la trajectoire
définie par le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
ainsi se font de t-il sur un scénario de
croissance en 2024 que le Haut Conseil
en accord avec de nombreux économistes
trouvent optimistes sans doute
pourrez-vous apporter des éléments de
réponse sur ce point
comme l'an passé le gouvernement a fait
précéder ce dépôt d'une phase de
consultation sous la forme des dialogues
de Bercy certains d'entre nous du bureau
notamment pu participer mais nos
collègues auront certainement de
nombreux sujets à aborder avec vous cet
après-midi
nous attendons désormais la phase
proprement dite d'examen parlementaire
au projet de loi de finance je vous
laisse donc la parole pour un propos
liminaire avant de venir aux questions
que le rapporteur général et l'ensemble
des commissaires des finances
souhaiteront vous poser je vous rappelle
que traditionnellement comme de
traditions cette audition est
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat ainsi que sur les comptes Facebook
Twitter
LinkedIn et YouTube du Sénat
le ministre monsieur le Maire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
cher Thomas Cazenave je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver pour la 7e
fois pour présenter ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2024
projet de loi de finance qui j'ai
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises et présenté dans un contexte
très particulier
où l'économie française résiste un pour
cent de croissance de la création
d'emplois qui se poursuit un pays qui
est devenu le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers en Europe mais
dans le même temps une inflation
persistante aussi qui brouille tous les
repères qui pèse terriblement sur la vie
quotidienne de nos compatriotes et qui
suscite beaucoup d'anxiété pour ne pas
dire de nervosité dans la société
française
ce palais de donc répondre à trois défis
qui s'inscrivent dans des calendriers
différents
le premier défi c'est mater l'inflation
définitivement
et c'est le défi le plus important
le deuxième défi c'est de désendetter le
pays et de réduire les déficits ce qui
est comme le premier président de la
Cour des comptes de la rappeler à
l'impératif catégorique quand les taux
d'intérêt ont pris 300 points de base en
l'espace de quelques années
le troisième défi c'est de dégager des
marges de manœuvre un moment où il est
aussi indispensable d'investir sur la
transition écologique mais aussi sur la
défense et la sécurité face au retour de
la guerre en Europe c'est ces trois
défis qui paraissent contradictoires
qu'il faut rendre conciliable dans ce
PLF la lutte contre l'inflation le
rétablissement des comptes et
l'investissement
ça suppose de la méthode cela suppose de
la détermination et cela suppose une
très grande clarté dans les choix
politiques
d'abord mettre fin à la flambée des prix
et poursuit cette lutte contre
l'inflation qui commence à donner des
résultats puisque l'inflation ralentit
aujourd'hui en France
ce choix là implique un choix de
politique budgétaire cohérent par
rapport à la politique monétaire de la
Banque centrale européenne je voudrais
juste un instant m'arrêter à cette
question de politique macroéconomique
rien ne serait plus absurde même si
c'est tentant que d'ouvrir tout grand
les vannes de la dépense budgétaire au
moment où l'argent devient cher ou la
Banque centrale européenne restreint au
contraire la mise à disposition de
liquidités si d'un côté la BCE appuie
sur le frein et que nous nous appuyons
sur l'accélérateur nous irons tous dans
le décor premier choix de politique
économique clair et assumé nous ne
pouvons pas rouvrir à nouveau les vannes
de la dépense budgétaire d'abord parce
que notre situation de finance publique
ne le permet pas mais parce qu'en plus
d'un point de vue de politique
économique ce serait absurde et en
contradiction totale avec les efforts de
la BCE de ramener l'inflation au niveau
cible de 2%
. deuxième élément et deuxième principe
de politique publique les temps ne peut
pas tout payer
et donc le choix que nous avons fait qui
nous attire parfois des moqueries mais
ça fait partie de la vie politique je le
revendique il faut faire appel au
distributeur il faut faire appel aux
industriels il faut faire appel aux
entreprises privées et peu importe les
moqueries sur le fait que le
gouvernement demande ceci ou cela moi je
constate que nous obtenons et que je
préfère obtenir des efforts de la part
des industriels et des distributeurs que
de céder la facilité de la dépense
publique oui nous avons travaillé avec
Olivia Grégoire pendant plusieurs
semaines sur les prix dans la grande
distribution et nous avons obtenu des
industriels et des distributeurs 5000
références sur lesquels les prix sont
bloqués ou baisse je préfère ça plutôt
que de nouvelles subventions ou de
nouvelles aides nous avons demandé à
total de bloquer au-delà du 31 décembre
les prix à la pompe à 1,99 le litre nous
l'avons obtenu
nous avons demandé à un certain nombre
de distributeurs de vendre à prix
coûtant nous l'avons obtenu et donc quel
que soit les moqueries que peuvent nous
attirer ces choix politiques nous les
maintiendrons parce que nous ne
viendrons à bout de l'inflation que
collectivement et que l'idée de faire
toujours appel à la dépense budgétaire à
la dépense publique est une bien
mauvaise idée quand nous avons une
charge de la dette qui représente 74
milliards d'euros en 2027
c'est d'autant plus vrai que je le
rappelle l'État prend toute sa part
il prend toute sa part d'abord avec
l'indexation des prestations sociales
l'indexation des retraites et
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu le bouclier anti-inflation il est
là
toutes les prestations sociales toutes
les retraites et le barème de l'IR sont
indexés sur l'inflation ça représente
4,5 milliards d'euros point d'exclation
des prestations sociales et des minima
sociaux ça représente 14 milliards
d'euros de dépenses publiques pour les
retraites et ça représente 6 milliards
d'euros pour l'impôt sur le revenu 25
milliards d'euros au total on peut dire
que l'État prend toute sa part dans la
lutte contre l'inflation et dans la
protection de nos compatriotes là aussi
soyons très clair quand j'entends
certains dire que l'inflation remplit
les poches de l'état c'est soit
malhonnête
soit mauvaise information de la part de
ce qui s'exprime donc comme je ne peux
pas croire la malhonnêteté des
responsables politiques de quelques
bords qu'ils soient je leur donnait
l'information
l'augmentation des recettes de TVA liées
à l'inflation c'est 10 milliards d'euros
voyez bien que c'est moins de deux fois
moins que ce que nous dépensons rien que
pour la revalorisation des retraites des
minimas et du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour dire les choses encore plus
simplement l'inflation coûte très cher à
l'État très cher et je ne laisserai
personne personne personne dire que
l'État s'en met plein les poches parce
que c'est affaiblir l'État c'est
affaiblir le rôle qu'il a à jouer je le
dis à tous ceux qui veulent devenir chef
de l'État un jour il est bien mal avisé
d'aller critiquer le comportement de
l'État qui protège et ne cherche pas à
se remplir les poches en période
inflationniste mais au contraire dépense
plus qu'il ne reçoit
enfin face à la situation très
particulière sur les carburants nous
avons pris des décisions pour protéger
ceux qui travaillent et nous assumons ce
choix de ciblage peut faire l'objet d'un
débat parfaitement légitime mais nous
nous pensons que ce qu'il faut aider en
priorité c'est tous ceux qui se rendent
sur le lieu de travail dans ma
circonscription rurales il y a des
personnes qui font cinq ans 60 120 km
par jour et pour lesquels certains le
savent parfaitement bien ici Monsieur
sénateur Moret l'augmentation du coût
des carburants est insupportable parce
que ça leur coûte plus cher d'aller
travailler que de rester chez eux et
comme le coeur de notre politique c'est
travail nous avons décidé de mettre en
place cette indemnité carburant
travailleur pour les 5 premiers des cils
concernant 4,3 millions de personnes qui
travaillent l'indemnité et fonction de
votre véhicule assuré bien entendu elle
représente 100 euros soit une économie
de 20 centimes par litre de carburant
sur 6 mois cette dépense elle me paraît
légitime et nécessaire voilà pour ce
petit concerne le premier objectif du
PLF faire baisser l'inflation et
protéger ceux qui en souffrent le plus
c'est-à-dire les plus modestes selon les
revenus sont les plus faibles
ce premier défi doit se conjuguer avec
le deuxième qui est d'accélérer notre
désendettement l'objectif à long terme
il est fixé
2,7% de déficit public en 2027 108% de
dettes et un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire qui doit baisser de 4,35,4 à
44,4 % pour tenir cette trajectoire il
faut que le pied d'appel soit solide
c'est ce projet de loi de finance qui
engage 16 milliards d'euros d'économies
certains trouveront ce n'est pas
suffisant ces économies ne sont pas
faciles contrairement à ce que j'entends
dire aussi ici ou là ça n'est pas facile
de retirer totalement le bouclier sur le
gaz et sur l'électricité nous le ferons
parce que les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité sont revenus à la normale
ça représente 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies
ça n'est pas simple de faire des
économistes et politiques de l'emploi
nous le ferons à partir du moment où
nous approchons du plein d'emploi nous
paraît légitime de faire ces économies
notamment sur le coup contrat des
entreprises et nous recentrerons les
dispositifs d'aide exceptionnelle aux
entreprises pour une économie de 4,4
milliards d'euros au total l'état
dépensera 491 milliards en 2024 c'était
496 en 2023 nous dépensons donc 5
milliards d'euros de moins et fort
notable dans une période d'inflation
cette première marche doit être
accompagnée d'une politique plus
structurelle de réduction des déficits
de choix plus avisés en matière de
dépenses publiques et d'accélération du
désendettement
cette accélération du désendettement
elle reposera sur trois principes très
simples le premier c'est la croissance
je ne crois absolument pas un
désendettement par l'austérité
l'austérité tue la croissance c'est la
croissance qui permet en priorité
absolue de réduire le niveau de dette
publique par rapport à notre richesse la
meilleure façon de réduire la part de la
République dans la richesse c'est
d'abord d'augmenter la richesse par la
croissance et ça restera le principe
cardinal notre politique si nous voulons
continuer à baisser des impôts si nous
voulons engager une baisse de 1 milliard
d'euros de la CVE l'année prochaine
c'est d'abord parce que ça nourrit la
croissance qui elle-même permet
d'augmenter notre prospérité de réduire
la part de la dette publique
le deuxième levier ce sont les réformes
de structure réforme des retraites et
réformes l'assurance chômage rapporte à
L2 près de 25 milliards d'euros à
horizon 2027 seuls les réformes de
structure permet de dégager des
économies aussi significatives enfin le
troisième levier ce sont les revues de
dépenses publiques qui ont déjà permis
d'identifier 2 milliards d'économies à
terme sur le Pinel plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros sur les opérateurs
de l'État je vous annonce que ces revues
de dépenses publiques seront poursuivis
chaque année jusqu'en 2027 à raison
d'une quinzaine de secteurs publics qui
seront examinés chaque année avec un
objectif d'avoir un rendement encore
plus élevé que celui que nous avons eu
pour le PLF 2024 et un objectif très
simple mieux dépenser l'argent des
Français
je veux être clair également sur le fait
que ces revues de dépenses aussi
nécessaires soient-elles de sauront pas
suffisantes et que pour être efficace et
durable nos revues de dépenses doivent
s'inscrire dans une réflexion plus
globale sur la redéfinition des missions
de l'État sur le périmètre de l'action
publique et sur des fondements notre
modèle social nous sommes arrivés au
point où ce débat démocratique doit
avoir lieu et il n'y aura pas
d'équilibre dans les finances publiques
sans réflexion sur d'autres modèles
social et sur le périmètre de l'État
j'invite tous les parlementaires qui le
souhaitent à participer à ces travaux
le troisième objectif c'est donc la
préparation de l'avenir et
l'investissement dans l'avenir dont je
parlais en introduction cet
investissement il va d'abord porter sur
l'éducation et sur la santé priorité du
président de la République en deuxième
lieu sur le régalien avec les lois de
programmation militaires des lois de
programmation sur l'intérieur de la
programmation sur la justice qui doivent
permettre de garantir la sécurité de nos
compatriotes et cet investissement il
doit porter aussi en priorité absolue
sur la décarbonation de notre économie
avec l'objectif de faire de la France la
première économie des carbonée horizon
2040 en Europe nous porterons donc le
budget de ma prime rénov à 5 milliards
d'euros par an nous amplifierons nos
véhicules se Vénus sur les véhicules
électriques notamment par le bonus et
par la mise en place de leasing à 100
euros par mois dès l'ami novembre et
nous continuerons à favoriser la
production d'énergie nucléaire en ache
négociation avec EDF sur le tarif de
l'électricité
enfin ces investissements des
bicarbonation devront reposer aussi sur
la conversion de notre fiscalité qui
doit passer d'une fiscalité avec des
avantages pour les énergies fossiles à
une fiscalité avec des avantages
exclusifs pour les énergies vertes
l'accord que nous avons trouvé avec les
agriculteurs et avec les travaux publics
sur cette transformation de la fiscalité
brune la fiscalité verte montre que dans
le dialogue sur la base de compromis et
surtout sur la base un accompagnement
d'un renversement de l'intégralité des
recettes supplémentaires du fossile vers
le verre on peut parvenir à modifier
cette fiscalité dans le dialogue dans le
compromis et sur la base d'un accord
solide voilà les quelques éléments que
je voulais vous présenter en
introduction avant de répondre à vos
questions
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
donner maintenant la parole Thomas
Cazenave ministre du budget des comptes
publics merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi
tout d'abord monsieur le Président de
vous remercier pour votre accueil au
sein de la commission des finances ici
au Sénat et avec les parlementaires il y
a une tradition du ministre du Budget
qui a avec une spécialité régionale ce
que j'ai fait il y a quelques heures et
je me suis autorisé avec le président
rénal à pouvoir vous amener quelques
cannelés que vous pourrez j'espère
déguster apprécié à l'issue de notre de
notre audition
non n'y voyez aucune ma liste de ma part
mais plutôt une forme de paralysme des
formes qui me semble bienvenue dans
cette dans cette peut-être nouvelle
tradition qui pourrait s'installer ici
au Sénat bon très heureux d'être
devant la commission aux des finances
pour présenter avec Bruno Le Maire ce
budget qui est le résultat à la fois
d'une méthode celle du dialogue j'y
reviendrai d'un esprit celui de la
responsabilité Bruno Le Maire largement
évoqué d'une boussole agir pour agir
pour l'avenir c'est d'abord ce projet de
loi de finance pour 2024 la consécration
de la transition écologique comme une
urgence absolue
avec ce budget nous permettons un
financement historique parce qu'à côté
de notre dette financière nous avons une
dette écologique à laquelle ce budget
permet de s'attaquer le projet de loi de
finance prévoit l'investissement
supplémentaire de 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dédiés au financement de
la transition écologique et donc à la
mise en œuvre de la stratégie de
planification écologique présentée par
la première ministre et qui se traduit
très concrètement par 7 milliards
d'euros de crédit de paiement
supplémentaires je vais vous donner
quelques exemples très concrets en
matière de transport nous permettons la
construction des RER métropolitains dans
le cadre de la prochaine génération des
contrats de plan est en région
550 millions d'euros seront engagés pour
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments de
l'État
pour l'agriculture un exemple parmi bien
d'autres et celui du plan et qui
bénéficiera de 110 millions d'euros
d'engagement le fond chaleur recevra 300
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour le
chauffage urbain et la décarbonation du
chauffage des entreprises et des ménages
nos collectivités locales bénéficieront
aussi de cet investissement avec le fond
vert qui est pérennisé d'une part et
porté à 2,5 milliards d'euros dont 500
millions d'euros pour la rénovation des
écoles comme annoncé par le président de
la République nous inciterons tous les
acteurs à s'engager en faveur de la
transition écologique en créant un
crédit d'impôt pour l'investissement
dans l'industrie verte pour soutenir la
décarbonation de notre industrie mais
aussi en renforçant les malus automobile
pour les voitures les plus polluantes
nous cherchons amplifier tous les
leviers pour le financement de la
transition écologique en dotant par
exemple le futur plan d'épargne avec son
climatique d'un régime fiscal incitatif
et en mettant à contribution les
gestionnaires des infrastructures des
transports les plus émetteurs pour
financer le de sport ferroviaire en
particulier les collectivités ont aussi
un rôle majeur à jouer nous travaillons
avec les associations d'élus pour
permettre la généralisation des budgets
verts dans les collectivités
territoriales l'enjeu est de nous doter
d'une boussole commune au-delà nous
devons adapter nos outils financiers à
la nouvelle donne écologique ce budget
est aussi celui du réarmement des
services publics pour nos concitoyens
nous investissons massivement dans nos
services publics qui sont garants de
notre cohésion sociale l'augmentation
est de 3,9 milliards d'euros pour
l'Éducation Nationale 1 milliard d'euros
pour la recherche et l'enseignement
supérieur 3,3 milliards d'euros pour nos
armées un milliard d'euros pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur 500 millions
d'euros pour notre justice ainsi nous
apportant les finançants financement
pour augmenter la rémunération des
enseignants pour permettre la poursuite
du programme d'investissement dans les
matériels prévus par la loi de
programmation militaire pour acquérir de
nouveaux matériels pour notre police
mais au-delà de ces chiffres le service
public ce sont des femmes et des hommes
ce budget 2024 va permettre de recruter
6700 agents publics supplémentaires dans
l'état
1580 dans les opérateurs de l'État nous
créons 3000 postes d'Ash 1900 post dans
la justice 2600 postes dans la police et
pour mettre en œuvre la transition
écologique 700 agents supplémentaires
s'il en était besoin ses créations sont
une réponse à ceux qui nous reprochent
d'avoir délaissé nos services publics
rien n'est plus faux et enfin qu'on
arrête et je sais ici que cela prend
tout son sens
d'opposer l'État et les collectivités
nous pourtant ensemble les services
publics les concours financiers de
l'Etat aux collectivité s'élèvent à 54,8
milliards d'euros en 2024 et la dotation
globale de fonctionnement augmentera à
nouveau de 220 millions d'euros après
une hausse en 2023 qui était la première
depuis 12 ans
dès cet exercice budgétaire pour
renforcer les capacités d'investissement
des collectivités nous étendons le Fonds
de compensation de la TVA aux dépenses
aménagement et je sais que cette
évolution était très attendue par de
très nombreux élus et de très nombreux
parlementaires cela répond une demande
qui représente un effort de 250 millions
d'euros pour l'investissement public
local
ce projet de loi de finance ce sont
aussi des grands équilibres avec un cap
clair celui de la réduction des déficits
publics
investir pour l'avenir c'est maîtriser
nos comptes publics je souhaite vous
tenir un langage de vérité puisque vous
connaissez aussi la réalité de nos
comptes si l'État a pu protéger
massivement c'est qu'il avait réduit son
déficit public en 2018 à 2,3 %. un état
qui consacre plus aux intérêts de la
dette qu'au budget de l'Éducation
nationale ce qui sera le cas en 2027 ne
peut plus prétendre être tourné vers
l'avenir et dépenses de l'État vont
passer de
496 milliards d'euros à 490 milliards
d'euros cette baisse est historique la
baisse des dépenses de l'État s'explique
d'abord par la sortie des dispositifs de
crise les mesures exceptionnelles mises
en oeuvre au plus haut de la crise
énergétique ne peuvent pas durer et donc
nous devons sortir progressivement et ce
sera le cas en 2024 où nous dépenserons
14 milliards d'euros de moins sur les
mesures exceptionnelles mises en œuvre
mais en même temps nous devons lutter
contre la vie chère et redonner du point
d'achat aux Français c'est pour cela que
nous revalorisons les tranches du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu tout comme les
pensions et les minimas sociaux ancrés
en véritable bouclier contre l'inflation
les économies sur le budget et elles
sont importantes viennent des réformes
structuelles également 350 millions
d'euros d'économies sur la politique de
l'emploi avec la réduction de notre
chômage et puis 500 millions d'euros en
améliorant l'efficacité et l'efficience
de notre politique de formation
professionnelle ainsi le déficit
budgétaire en 2024 va baisser passant de
165 milliards d'euros à 145 milliards
d'euros et nous tiendrons la cible des
4,4% de soldes publics nous devons et
Bruno Le Maire la rappeler continuer
dans cette lancée dès 2025 trouver 12
milliards d'euros d'économistes
structurelles et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons relancer et muscler
le processus de revue de dépenses qui
associera naturellement les
parlementaires
enfin ce PLF est un PLF antiphrod avant
d'être en enjeu financier la lutte
contre la fraude est un enjeu de
cohésion et de justice sociale pas de
consentement à l'impôt si l'État n'est
pas en mesure de garantir à nos
concitoyens que tous ceux qui doivent
payer des impôts les payent
effectivement le projet de loi de
finance et aussi le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale vont
insérer une dizaine d'outils juridiques
nouveaux pour mieux lutter contre la
fraude je vous en donne quelques
exemples face à la nouvelle donne
numérique nos administrations pourront
défencer les vendeurs des plateformes
numériques qui ne respectent pas leurs
obligations fiscales nous allons
permettre aux agents du fisc de mener
des cyber enquêtes sous pseudonymes nous
lutterons contre ceux qui achètent à
l'étranger et revendre en France sans
payer la TVA nous allons créer une peine
complémentaire de privation des
bénéfices des crédits réductions
d'impôts pour les particuliers condamnés
nous mettrons en place un nouveau délit
d'incitation à la fraude fiscale afin de
poursuivre tous les intermédiaires qui
proposent des montages d'évasion fiscale
sans attendre la condamnation de leurs
clients c'est une manière d'empêcher la
fraude à la source et nous le ferons
également pour les fraudes aux aides
sociales et enfin nous créons une
sanction administrative pour lutter
contre la fraude aux aides publiques en
parallèle de la création de 1500 postes
à la DG FIP sur le contrôle fiscal c'est
mille agents supplémentaires d'ici 2027
qui seront consacrés à la lutte contre
la fraude au sein des caisses de
sécurité sociale
enfin nous devons renforcer la sécurité
de nos agents en leur permettant de
délocaliser certains contrôles et de
réaliser des contrôles de manière
anonyme pour les protéger faisant un
coup ainsi au drame qui est survenu en
novembre dernier il s'agit là de mesure
que nous proposons dès le texte initial
mais nous sommes en situation de
l'enrichir lors des dialogues de Bercy
et certains d'entre vous y ont participé
la lutte contre la fraude a été évoquée
par la plupart des participants et nous
sommes preneurs de vos propositions dans
ce domaine comme dans d'autres enfin ce
PLF c'est une méthode le dialogue comme
je le disais j'ai réuni les
parlementaires de tout bord lors des
dialogues de Bercy ou lors des réunions
bilatérales et nous avons associé
naturellement les associations d'élus
locaux les entreprises pour construire
ce budget
c'est aussi je l'ai dit la main tendue
au collectivités territoriales dans le
cadre du Pacte Girondins que nous avons
créé avec Bruno Le Maire le Haut Conseil
au finances publiques locales pour
échanger des galets égales entre l'État
et les collectivités territoriales et
s'agissant du PLF à l'issue des
dialogues de Bercy nous avons identifié
des thématiques communes sur lesquelles
les groupes d'horizons différents du
Sénat comme de l'Assemblée souhaité
travailler je pense au logement je pense
à la justice fiscale notamment à la
transition écologique pour lesquelles
nous sommes à disposition pour continuer
à enrichir le texte le texte qui vous
est présenté est un texte initial qui
n'est pas le texte final je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général
oui merci merci messieurs les ministres
je vais à mon tour comme le président
Claude Raynal
remercier
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances durables puisque finalement il
est un peu inoxydable depuis le premier
gouvernement
mis en place en 2017 à l'issue de
l'élection de du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron et puis vous
souhaitez monsieur le ministre des
comptes publics la bienvenue vous verrez
ici les débats sont toujours
constructifs apaisés on n'est pas
toujours d'accord et c'est heureux pour
sortir comme un certain nombre d'entre
nous d'une période de intense de
dialogue et de visite sur le terrain il
y a un monde entre une partie des propos
que j'ai entendu parler de ministres et
la situation en tous les cas telle
qu'elle aurait ressenti sur les
territoires
quelques éléments très rapidement deux
éléments concernant les grands
équilibres de ce PLF que je vois qui
nous interpelle d'abord le premier il
n'est pas neutre ni main surtout c'est
de constater qu'avec les transferts de
TVA le budget de l'État devient
hypersensible si je peux le dire ainsi à
la volatilité volatilité de l'impôt sur
les sociétés qui prend désormais une
place essentielle dans ses ressources ce
qui me semble-t-il n'est ni souhaitable
ni bon et puis
subrepticement un deuxième sujet qui
concerne l'évolution des emplois puisque
c'est près de 11000 ETP supplémentaires
qui me conduisent à interroger le
gouvernement et messieurs les ministres
vous interrogez sur la ligne du
gouvernement y a-t-il une nouvelle ligne
et pour nous la définir en matière de
fonction publique puisque j'avais bien
entendu qu'il y avait
le pré rappelé qui avait renoncé à la
suppression en fin de quinquennat de 50
000 postes dans la fonction publique
d'État
quel est aujourd'hui la trajectoire si
on peut la connaître puisque sauf faire
de ma part elle n'a pas été non plus
évoquée dans la prise de parole du plan
République dimanche soir dernier
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie j'ai
essayé de faire un peu le comment
dirais-je de regarder un peu en arrière
et je vais vous le dire tout de suite je
suis assez frappé par votre souplesse ce
que j'appellerai la pratique du grand
écart d'un côté vous présentez
une image sérieuse
apôtre la rigueur pour pas dire parfois
d'une forme d'austérité
souriante parfois mais je constate en
même temps que depuis six ans que vous
êtes au finance jamais vous n'avez
baissé la dépense publique quoi que vous
veniez de dire il y a quelques instants
même
en enlevant les mesures exceptionnelles
même en avant les mesures de crise les
dépenses publiques ont augmenté quand la
calcule en valeur quand la calcul en
volume la dépense augmente
tous les jours ou presque
des annonces de dépenses nouvelles de
telles ou tel ministre Premier ministre
et parfois présent la République
viennent charger la barque
le projet de loi de finance 2024 prévoit
encore une hausse de plus de 2% pour
être précis de 2,2% des dépenses hors
mesure exceptionnelles
et je le redis même en intégrant la
disparition des dépenses exceptionnelles
dépensent d'urgence et de relance les
dépenses continuent d'augmenter je pense
monsieur le ministre puisque vous l'avez
dit vous-même
il faut être comment dirais-je
plus précisément actif et peut-être
que moins de déclarations interviennent
finissant par perdre l'opinion les élus
avec le danger que ça présente comme l'a
dit à l'époque le président de la
République la finance magique je dirais
même les finances magiques effectivement
ça n'existe pas
des dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'économie mais finalement quand on
regarde la rue dépenses que vous avez
rendu au Parlement en juillet
je ne vois pas
d'économie je ne vois pas d'économie
quasiment toutes les missions
budgétaires continuent d'être à la
hausse d'ailleurs vous en avez
vous avez fait un florilège annonçant
des plus un peu partout
la réalité en fait c'est l'absence quasi
totale d'économie structurelle monsieur
mise de l'économie vous nous l'avait dit
dans le PDF que vous nous présentez et
d'ailleurs vous financez des mesures
pérennes malheureusement grâce à la
disparition des dispositifs
exceptionnels je redis relance
urgence la réalité en fait
c'est que vous tentez comme l'an dernier
d'ailleurs de renvoyer la balle pour ne
pas dire la responsabilité au
parlementaire messieurs les ministres
chacun doit être dans son rôle on a un
exécutif et un gouvernement qui doit
assumer des choix les proposer et
ensuite le Parlement les deux assemblées
viendront à se prononcer
ce qui m'amène à vous poser une première
question monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances monsieur le
ministre des comptes publics à quel
moment allez vous proposer
une réduction de la dépense publique ce
que j'appellerais une meilleure gestion
de nos finances publiques
un deuxième sujet qui est plus ponctuel
la question du carburant vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre je sais plus vous
avez beaucoup parlé de moquerie moi je
suis pas là pour me moquer je vais juste
très rapidement essayer de faire
de rappeler les quelques déclarations
toutes récentes du gouvernement parce
que j'ai eu un peu de mal à suivre alors
il y a d'abord eu la remise généralisée
l'an passé qui Sauveur de ma part a
coûté 8 milliards d'euros
puis il y a eu le chèque carburant puis
vous avez annoncé récemment par la voix
de la première ministre l'annonce de
l'autorisation de la vente à perte qui
devait faire l'objet d'un projet de loi
mais il semblerait qu'elle est avortée
moins d'une semaine après son lancement
et aujourd'hui vous nous parlez d'une
aide ciblée suis-je bien retenu de 100
euros pour des ménages modestes 100
euros pardon pour l'année oui pardon
pour l'année par ménage là encore
moi je vous pose la question
l'objectif
quels sont les montants que vous pensez
qui seront consacrés et combien de
foyers touchent-ils enfin vous pouvez
nous dire quel est le niveau de
consommation des crédits effectifs
relatifs à l'aide ciblée des gros
rouleurs qui a été mise en œuvre en 2023
combien y a-t-il eu de bénéficiaires
puisque je rappelle pour nos collègues
un milliard d'euros avaient été inscrits
en crédit pour l'année 2023
puisque je parlais de carburant je vais
redire un mot monsieur mise de
l'économie parce que c'est important et
que je crois que nous ne sommes pas
sortis du dispositif
et des difficultés notamment pour les
entreprises mais aussi pour les ménages
concernant le prix de l'énergie
et même le prix de l'électricité puisque
pour les particuliers
vous avez dit que vous ne laisseriez pas
ce prix augmenter de plus de 10% en
février prochain comme les hypothèses de
la Commission de régulation de l'énergie
le prévoit mais je le redis quand même
l'an passé par une augmentation de 10%
mise en œuvre en catimini au milieu de
l'été vous avez remis en cause
l'engagement que vous aviez pris
initialement de plafonner l'augmentation
à 15% sur l'année
je vous pose une question
peut-on vous croire dans l'annonce que
vous faites pour 2024 puisque nous je
souligne que vous n'avez pas tenu votre
parole pour 2023 et cet engagement
est-il à ce jour compatible avec la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte enfin une
dernière question qui
touche à certains
enjeux notamment de transposition de la
directive européenne qui vise assurer un
niveau minimum d'imposition mondiale
pour les grandes entreprises c'est un
sujet que nous avons
plusieurs fois abordé dans nos travaux
de commission le taux du nouvel impôt
proposé on le sait a été fixé au niveau
mondial à 15%,
comment ce taux va-t-il s'articuler avec
l'impôt sur les sociétés dont le taux
est lui actuellement à 25% et surtout
peut-être puisque nous sommes
au moment d'étudier le PLF en tous les
cas en commission quels sont les
estimations du gouvernement quand au
recettes fiscales que cette impôt
pourrait produire en France je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
comme vous le voyez monsieur et les
ministres rien ne vaut une bonne séance
de rentrée pour avoir un nombre de
questions significatives à la fois du
rapporteur général et puis vous verrez
je crois que tout le monde ne prend pas
la parole mais on n'est pas loin quand
même donc ça va être bien ici les
ministres
merci monsieur le Président c'est
toujours un plaisir de répondre aux
rapporteur général
sur toutes les questions pertinentes qui
viennent d'être posées
je partage votre avis sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés sur la TVA mais il se
trouve que tout le monde veut la TVA
donc effectivement une des évolutions
sur laquelle on peut s'interroger depuis
plusieurs années c'est que la part de
recettes de TVA qui revient à l'étain et
maintenant tout juste à 50%. la moitié
mais quand on supprime la taxe
d'habitation pour 20 milliards d'euros
quelle est la compensation que veulent
les collectivités locales qui veulent
une recette dynamique c'est la TVA et
sur quasiment toutes les recettes
je dis simplement que la TVA est en une
recette dynamique preuve d'ailleurs de
la vertu de notre politique économique
parce qu'elle crée de la croissance et
donc des recettes de TVA supplémentaires
tout le monde veut de la TVA mais on
peut partager effectivement cette
interrogation ensuite sur la rigueur sur
l'austérité je ne suis pas un impôtre de
l'austérité mais en revanche je suis un
apôtre des comptes publics bien tenus et
je rappelle puisque vous avez dit que
j'étais un ministre des Finances
inoxydable qu'en 2017 et en 2018 nous
avons rétabli nos finances publiques
nous sommes revenus sous les 3% de
déficit et nous sommes sortis la
procédure pour des sites publiques
excessifs avec des décisions qui est des
décisions courageuses on a supprimé par
exemple tous les emplois aidés
honnêtement c'était pas une décision
facile on a pris un certain nombre de
décision structurelle qui nous ont
permis de revenir sur les 3% et j'invite
je vais y revenir la majorité et tous
ceux qui partagent cet objectif de
rétablissement des finances publiques
des propositions pour revenir sous les
3% de lucides publiques en
2027 mon objectif donc des palostérités
c'est d'avoir de la dépense publique
bien employée et une dépense publique
qui augmente moins vite que l'inflation
c'est ça l'objectif et avoir un niveau
de prospérité qui augmente plus vite que
la dette ce n'était pas DBC à dépenses
pour baisser la dépense c'est employer
bien l'argent des Français et s'assurer
que la dépense publique n'augmente pas
plus rapidement que l'inflation moi
j'observe puisque vous avez fait preuve
de malice se faire preuve d'un tout
petit peu de malice que dans votre
famille politique dans le fond il y a
deux camps
il y a ceux qui nous disent faut
rétablir les finances publiques mais qui
ne cessent de proposer des dépenses
supplémentaires
j'ai entendu certains qui me disaient
vous supprimer la TVA sur les carburants
10 milliards d'euros d'autres qui
proposaient de faire une remise sur les
carburants comme on l'a fait l'année
dernière sur proposition du groupe LR à
l'Assemblée nationale je le rappelle ça
coûte 12 milliards d'euros et puis il y
a ce en tête Bono Retailleau le
président du groupe LR et le président
du Sénat dont je salue évidemment dans
cette maison la sagesse qui
immédiatement on dit ben non c'est pas
possible
moi je me range plutôt du côté de Bruno
Retailleau et de Gérard Larcher a
considérer que faire des remises
générales sur les carburants c'est une
triple erreur
c'est mais nous l'avons commis sur
proposition du groupe Lrl Assemblée
nationale je suis obligé de le noter
mais je suis obligé de le reconnaître
moi il en quoi je le redis c'est une
triple erreur c'est une erreur pour
notre finance publique
que ça coûte trop cher c'est une erreur
pour le climat parce que ça revient la
subventionné les énergies fossiles et
puis c'est une erreur géopolitique
puisque nous savons que la Russie comme
l'Arabie saoudite ont pris la décision
de réduire le volume de production de
pétrole et de faire augmenter les prix
et que par conséquent sont tout devrais
semblance les prix du baril se
stabiliseront ou augmenteront au dessus
du niveau actuel de 85 dollars le baril
dans les mois à venir donc
entraîner nos finances publiques dans un
puits sans fond qui est celui de la
remise sur le carburants et entraîner
nos propres compatriotes dans cette
voie-là c'est totalement irresponsable
il faut aider ceux qui travaillent j'y
reviens c'est 17 et il faut accélérer
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
qui passe par le déploiement du véhicule
électrique par des solutions
alternatives par les biocarburants pour
les agriculteurs je sais bien que tout
cela prend du temps et qu'il y a un
problème de délai entre la la solution
immédiate qu'on apporte et ce que
peuvent se payer les contribuables mais
quand on met par exemple sur pied la
possibilité d'avoir un leasing à 100
euros dès le 15 novembre sans apport
initial et c'est une solution quand on
accélère le déploiement des bandes de
recharge rapide c'est une solution quand
on développe les bandes de recharge
rapide y compris dans les stations
rurales c'est une solution et je préfère
investir de l'argent là-dessus pour que
nous soyons indépendant indépendant
indépendant
je pense que tous ici nous avons compris
qu'être pieds et point liés à l'Arabie
Saoudite et la Russie en matière de
production de pétrole est une folie et
que mettre de l'argent public là-dedans
est une folie c'est pas facile à faire
comprendre je sais à quel point c'est
dur pour nos compatriotes mais je pense
qu'il est indispensable de tenir cette
ligne sinon on jette l'argent public pas
les fenêtres on les met dans le Main de
Monsieur Poutine ou de Mohamed Ben
Salman ça me paraît pas un très bon
emploi de l'argent public
sur la question de
l'électricité dans la question de l'ICT
donc ça concernera l'évaluation que
c'est sa concernera comme l'année
précédente 4,3 millions de foyers pour
un montant total de 430 millions d'euros
on peut débattre du ciblage bien entendu
nous nous privilégions évidemment les
personnes les plus modestes je rappelle
qu'une grande majorité de ces foyers
sont des foyers justement en zone rurale
ce qui me paraît parfaitement légitime
chez l'électricité je vous confirme j'ai
entendu la Creuse ou parler
d'augmentation de 10 à 20% au mois de
janvier il en est hors de question on
n'est pas là pour créer des inquiétudes
supplémentaires chez nos compatiale
qu'ils sont déjà suffisamment inquiets
nous verrons qu'elles seront les choix
que nous aurons à faire en fonction du
prix d'électricité moi ce que je
constate c'est que le prix d'électricité
a baissé parce que EDF produit davantage
et qu'il a réussi à remettre en
fonctionnement un certain nombre de
réacteurs qui étaient arrêtés pour des
questions de corrosion sous contrainte
je félicite les agents d'EDF parce que
c'est un boulot considérable qu'ils ont
fait dans des délais rapides et je pense
que la priorité absolue c'est d'avoir le
plus grand nombre possible de réacteurs
en état de fonctionnement et de réaliser
dans les délais impartis 2035 les 6
nouveaux EPR s'agissant de l'impôt
minimum à l'IS il sera effectivement à
partir de début 2025 parce que il y a
des sujets techniques importants à
régler et il devrait rapporter de
l'ordre de 1,5 1,6 milliards d'euros par
an vous voyez que c'est une recette
fiscale qui est significative
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général permettez-moi tout
d'abord de vous féliciter pour votre
réélection
sur les quelques questions
complémentaires sur sur le sujet des
économies en 2024 sur la part des
économies structurelles nous revoyons la
politique de l'emploi à mesure que le
chômage baisse quand on baisse le les
contrats aidé dans le secteur marchand
par exemple c'est bien qu'on adapte
notre politique à la nouvelle donne et
donc on revoit notre politique de
l'emploi de manière structurelle nous
faisons 500 millions d'euros sur la
politique et l'efficience de la
politique de formation en révisant les
coûts contrats c'est une politique qui
est une réforme structurelle les gains
générés par les bénéfices excédents
pardon générés par l'assurance chômage
c'est aussi la conséquence à la fois de
les bonnes performances de notre marché
du travail et aussi de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et enfin sur des
dispositifs fiscaux que nous avons
évalué et jugé peu efficace comme
le Pinel c'est aussi une réforme
structurelle donc il y a dès 2024
enclenché des politiques de réforme
structurelles mais elle devrait être
beaucoup plus importante à partir de
2025 avec les 12 milliards d'euros
attendus sur la question de l'évolution
de la de la dépense publique notre notre
trajectoire c'est bien de faire passer
la part des dépenses publiques dans le
PIB de 57,7% à
53,8%, c'est un effort aussi très
significatif parce que concrètement ça
veut dire qu'elle va progresser en
volume de 0,6% moins vite que le PIB
avec un effort renforcé sur le périmètre
état donc la trajectoire est une
trajectoire ambitieuse de baisse
progressive et continue de la dépense
publique et là-dessus comme d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée très ouvert à ce que des
propositions des parlementaires des
sénateurs viennent nous aider dans les
revues de dépenses d'ailleurs qui seront
ouvertes au Parlement pour nourrir ce
travail de réforme structurel il y a un
des chantiers de réforme structurelle
qui me semble indispensable à ouvrir et
nous l'avons déjà évoqué dans les
dialogues de Bercy le coût de notre
organisation collective génère une
dynamique de dépenses très importante
entre l'État ces agences et les
collectivités territoriales je suis
convaincu et les élus locaux nous le
disent il y a de quoi faire plus simple
et donc moins coûteux je pense que ce
serait très utile qu'ici nous puissions
travailler avec vous sur ce type de
réforme structurel qui permettrait de
ralentir le rythme de la dépense je vous
remercie
sur les chèques énergie ou la réduction
du prix de l'essence et c'est vrai vous
avez raison d'un côté LR à l'Assemblée
nationale je vous confirmer qu'ici
c'était beaucoup plus prudent
mais les députés LR à l'Assemblée
nationale ont effectivement porté ce
sujet c'est donc ils ont donc une part
de responsabilité dans les 12 milliards
de coups de la mesure et vous même
malheureusement en disant oui
au bénéfice d'une alliance dont on peut
dire qu'elle a été de circonstances elle
a pas duré très longtemps mais au final
ça a quand même coûté 12 milliards à
tout le monde donc j'ai du mal à vous
féliciter les uns et les autres
bon si on partage déjà ça
bon alors Michel Condé il marque la mini
alors je je vous précise comme vous le
savez les ministres ont quand même
toujours un temps au contraire donc si
vous pouviez choisir un thème et un seul
parce qu'on pourrait parler à l'infini
les uns et les autres ce serait bien
merci monsieur le Président bien entendu
ici nous préférons que le débat
parlementaire puisse permettre d'aboutir
à un budget qui soit le plus équilibré
plus possible plutôt que les seuls
dialogues de Bercy pour autant qu'il
soit utile néanmoins nous avions nous au
niveau du groupe de l'Union centriste et
c'est vrai formuler un certain nombre de
propositions l'année dernière notamment
la le report de la CVAE de la baisse de
la CVAE nous sommes heureux que le
gouvernement nous a entendu cette année
sur cette nécessité de reporter la
baisse des recettes
comme sur la redevance audiovisuelle
nous aurions souhaité aussi qu'elle
puisse se faire à un autre moment du
mandat parce que ce sont trois milliards
d'eux de dettes supplémentaires chaque
année à quoi on aboutit avec cette
mesure réalisée immédiatement dès
l'année dernière
et donc on espère pouvoir reformuler un
certain nombre d'autres propositions en
particulier sur la question du carburant
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure je
ne reviens pas sur les intervenants
évoqué par le rapporteur général mais
pour dire que les éventuelles aident
doivent être faites en direction de ceux
qui travaillent pour l'essentiel et
doivent être faites je partage votre
sentiment là-dessus monsieur le ministre
d'économie et des Finances avec des
employeurs parce que c'est bien au
secteur privé qu'il faut associer à tout
cela alors sur le logement par ailleurs
nous avons il faut le dire de vivre
inquiétudes parce qu'on voit bien que
celui-ci est en panne dans notre pays et
il nous semble qu'il serait opportun que
l'on puisse pour les ménages modestes
pour voir à disposer de prêt à taux zéro
qui permettent non seulement dans
certaines zones géographiques de notre
pays mais aussi dans les territoires
ruraux de pouvoir accéder à la propriété
de pouvoir accéder au logement ce qui
est un facteur essentiel pour
l'insertion et pour l'activité
professionnelle
je voulais aussi évoquer la question de
la fiscalité vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure l'accord qui a pu être trouvé
avec le secteur agricole il me semble
que pour le secteur des travaux publics
il serait important que l'on puisse
suivre la même trajectoire et non pas
prévoir une trajectoire qui soit
différenciée parce que cela va amener à
des inégalités de traitement et l'on
sait bien que tant qu'on n'a pas de mode
alternatif pour pouvoir travailler je
peux parler de mode de propulsion des
engins qui sont utilisés il est
difficile d'opérer une véritable
mutation donc progression vers la
taxation ou la réduction de la
de la taxation pardon de l'énergie
fossile mais soyons attentif à ce que
cela ne pénalise pas l'activité d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises parce qu'on
risque d'arriver à l'effet inverse et
notamment à des baisses d'autres
recettes je voulais aussi appeler votre
attention sur la difficulté du secteur
de la pêche qui souffre terriblement et
pour lesquelles il est nécessaire pour
pouvoir accompagner les entreprises si
on veut éviter le dépôt bilan ainsi que
en ce qui concerne les EHPAD puisque le
secteur social est aussi en difficulté
près de 90% des ehpads de notre pays
sont en déficit donc cela appellera des
mesures fortes je sais que la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale a un
équilibre qui est difficile mais il faut
qu'on soit attentif à ce que la
solidarité puisse exercer que ces EHPAD
puissent continuer à fonctionner puis
enfin je voulais appeler l'attention du
ministre des comptes publics sur le HTA
nous apprécions que l'on revienne à
remboursement de la question des
aménagements sur les terrains qui
n'auraient jamais dû être supprimés mais
persiste encore
le décalage de versement de la TVA à
beaucoup de collectivités ce qui semble
totalement normal et anormal que les
collectivités bénéficient de la TVA plus
de 2 ans après avoir réalisé
l'investissement il avait nécessaire que
l'on puisse évoluer là dessus
merci Michel Marc Lamini voudrait bien
prendre exemple sur Michel canevez et
vous en tenir un seul un seul sujet
merci oui merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer d'être court messieurs les
ministres sur le reportage général cher
collègue merci beaucoup pour votre
présentation du projet de loi de finance
pour
2024 moi je vais faire qu'un point et
même si on aurait beaucoup d'autres le
volet collectivité territorial ben cher
au président rénal et notre collègue
Charles Guénet puisque son rapport
heureux spéciaux vous les collectivités
territoriales bon que ce soit les
régions départements mais surtout les
communes on est attaché aussi à
l'échelon de base
les intercommunalités je dirais toujours
certes des même s'il y a eu des avancées
significatives il y a quand même le
problème
des de l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales parce que
actuellement les les communes il y a
seulement les taxes les plus les taxes
foncières même si taxe d'habitation est
compensée à l'euro près par l'État
l'état je suis objectif toujours
qui reste depuis historiquement le
premier partenaire des collectivités
territoriales en ce qui concerne
l'ensemble des dotations de
fonctionnement même si aussi des
inquiétudes sur certaines dotations la
DGF même s'il y a des revalorisations
comme les inquiétudes sur le dotation de
fonctionnement et puis quel avenir aussi
devenir pour les aides à
l'investissement que ce soit DETR des
cils vous avez évoqué aussi le fond vert
mais c'est pareil il y a aussi quand
même toujours des incertitudes dans la
matière et qu'elles sont aussi les les
avancées en la matière merci beaucoup
pardon merci Marc Hervé Moret
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres je suis toujours très étonné
quand j'entends des membres du
gouvernement de voir à quel point ils
pratiquent l'auto-satisfaction une
auto-satisfaction qui est
malheureusement très éloignée comme un
peu dit le rapporteur général
de terrain quand on est en campagne
comme il a été ou quand même quand on ne
l'est pas comme je le suis pour le
moment
deux trois points d'abord ce ministre
vous avez évoqué le niveau de la dette
en disant que c'était une priorité on a
quand même un niveau de dette qui n'a
jamais été atteint on va emprunter 285
milliards cette année on est le
troisième pays en termes de dette et ce
matin le président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques nous disait qu'on
pourrait faire beaucoup mieux sans
austérité alors pourquoi on ne fait pas
beaucoup mieux sans austérité sur les
finances locales le Conseil des finances
locales considèrent que le compte n'y
est pas le gouvernement annonce très
fièrement une augmentation de 220
millions des dotations ça représente à
peu près 0,8% alors que l'inflation des
collectivités locales est évaluées à 4
ou 5% entre 4 et 5% et donc il y aurait
encore cette année j'ai bien encore
cette année un milliard de pertes et je
crois qu'on peut pas indéfiniment faire
en sorte que les collectivités locales
servent d'amortisseur je vous indique
d'ailleurs que les mères ont été
extrêmement choqués dans le temps bien
la République mettre sur le dos des
communes l'augmentation de la taxe
foncière et puis j'en viens pour ne pas
être trop long sur les sujets de
mobilité parce que je suis avec Stéphane
sotarel rapporteur de ce budget pour
vous poser deux trois questions la taxe
sur les concessions devraient rapporter
600 millions d'euros comment ça se
répartit entre dans vos prévisions entre
l'aéroports et les autoroutes et surtout
comment éviter que juridiquement les ce
que paieront les concessions d'autoroute
se répercutent sur les usagers parce que
malheureusement les contrats concession
sont plus favorables aux sociétés
d'autoroute qu'aux usagers sur les 700
millions pour les infrastructures quelle
répartition entre le routier le
ferroviaire et notamment pour la
régénération et la modernisation du
ferroviaire et puis dernière question
vous avez accepté qu'il Île-de-France
mobilité augmente la part du versement
mobilité c'est un souhait que partage
toutes les autorités organisatrices de
mobilité et pas seulement Île-de-France
mobilité est-ce que c'est un précédent
comment interpréter cette autorisation
merci
merci Hervé Christine Labarde
merci alors moi j'ai trois questions
donc je vais aller très vite la première
question concerne le crédit d'impôt sur
l'industrie verte dont le coût cumulé a
fortement augmenté entre les annonces
initiales de milliards et ce qui figure
là trois milliards 7 pour autant j'avais
compris que le les coûts associés à
l'industrie verte devait être nulle pour
les finances publiques grâce aux
économies qu'elle allait être faites sur
les dépenses brunes donc comment est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous assurez cette
neutralité deuxième sujet le bonus
écologique vous êtes largement revenu
sur ce sujet il est par contre difficile
pour nous d'avoir un avis éclairé sur
les montants qui vont être alloués au
bonus cette année si on ne connaît pas
la grille des véhicules qui seront
éligibles ou qu'on la découvre au milieu
voir à la fin de l'instruction du PLF
donc il serait cohérent qu'on en dispose
avant l'étude des crédits de la mission
et là je vais être un peu plus long
parce que c'était un peu plus compliqué
et précis mais je pense que ça vous
concerne tous c'est le FCTVA donc nous
avons bien noté l'élargissement
de l'enveloppe que vous avez annoncé
donc j'aimerais que vous précisiez de
quelle enveloppe on parle désormais
s'agit-il uniquement du compte 212
agencement et aménagement de terrain et
des sous-comptes 21
et 21 28
mais que faites-vous à ce moment-là des
comptes 213 constructions et 215 réseaux
qui sont particulièrement utilisés dans
l'aménagement des actes par ailleurs
concernant l'aménagement des actes qui
repose sur des contrats de concession
il faudrait pour qu'ils puissent de
nouveau être éligible au FCTVA à revenir
sur l'abrogation qui a été faite en LFI
2019 de l'article
16-15-1 du CGCT donc ça nous n'allons
pas avoir le pouvoir de le faire puisque
nous sommes parlementaires et contraint
par l'article 40 le gouvernement peut le
faire et je souhaite toutes ces
précisions puisque finalement nous
allons voter que des crédits
un élargissement de l'enveloppe mais
tout ce que je viens d'évoquer et de
nature réglementaire donc j'aimerais
entendre les ministres sur ce point
avez juste sur l'enveloppe j'ai bien
noté que dans la LPFP 2022 il y avait 7
milliards de crédits qui étaient ouverts
en 2024 dans la nouvelle LPF est
corrigée il y en a 7 milliards 1 donc
j'observe une augmentation uniquement de
100 millions d'euros ce qui n'est pas
cohérent avec les 250 millions d'euros
que vous avez annoncé donc est-ce à dire
que vous avez revu la prévision on va
dire des dépenses socle dans la
trajectoire et vous avez bien ajouté 250
ou qu'en fait l'effort n'est que de 100
millions sur 2024 et quand sera-t-il des
dépenses de 2022 et de 2023 puisque
sinon on va avoir une règle un peu
différente entre ceux qui sont compensés
en N et ceux qui sont avec un encore un
peu du rebours
chers collègue je suis désespéré
Christine Lavarde d'habitude de la
Baudelaire qui rentre dans la minute
hélas alors Antoine Lefebvre on va
essayer messieurs le ministre mes chers
dans la dans le PLF il était présenté ce
matin au Conseil des ministres et dans
la LPFP les supposer que le gouvernement
fait preuve d'un optimisme qui excède un
peu la réalité les indicateurs
macroéconomiques plusieurs longs
souligné avant moi non seulement la
voilure des recettes budgétaires et
fiscales ce tarient mais l'État semble
aujourd'hui se réengager dans une
logique du quoi qu'il en coûte que
d'aucun qualifieront de court termiste
avec entre autres l'annonce ce dimanche
d'un nouveau chèque carburant pour les
50% des ménages les plus modestes avec à
la clé une addition de plus de 500
millions d'euros il apparaît donc plutôt
audacieux de se réjouir de prévisions de
croissance à 1,4% 2024 lorsque le
déficit demeurerait à 4,4% avec une
charge de la dette de ce 285 milliards
d'euros faisant de la France le premier
émetteur de la zone euro d'autant que
cette prévision de croissance ne saurait
être atteinte au respect de conditions
extrêmement optimistes comme indiqué ce
matin le premier président de la Cour
des comptes elle sera de ce croit le
dernier pays avec la Slovaquie à repassé
sous le seuil des 3% des visites en 2027
pour ma première question est la
suivante messieurs les ministres à
l'aube de la renégociation des critères
de Maastricht prévu en 2024 pensez-vous
tenir un discours crédible devant nos
partenaires européens l'année prochaine
et je le dis sans aucune malice et
deuxième question pouvez-vous garantir
que la promesse qui a été faite pour
geler le livret A à 3% jusqu'au 1er
janvier 2025 pourra être bien tenu merci
merci Antoine Christian Klinger
merci monsieur le Président je devrais
tenir la minute normalement
mais sur les ministres deux questions
s'agissant de l'augmentation de la
fiscalité sur le Gazole Non Routier donc
le GNR pour les agriculteurs et les
entrepreneurs de travaux publics vous
avez indiqué lundi devant la commission
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale
que l'augmentation de cette fiscalité
serait affectée à l'accompagnement de
ses professions
quel sera le bilan financier global de
cette mesure est-ce que toutes les
recettes fiscales supplémentaires
ont-elles vocation à être transformées
en dépense nouvelle et prévoyez-vous
donc d'instaurer dans le budget une
affectation juridique de ces recettes à
des dépenses si oui sous quelle forme et
quel suivi en sera-t-il fait
parfait Christian vous Daniel broyer
pour dire que vous avez une grande
constance et je la reconnais
dire aussi que j'étais heure
lorsqu'il vient se substituer au pétrole
mais c'est ce sont déjà des progrès
sémantiques que j'encourage comme je
trouve et je me permets de le dire
peut-être mes collègues me trouveront
trop généreux aujourd'hui que les 7
milliards consacrés supplémentaires
consacrés à la transition écologique
sont quand même une moyenne bonne
nouvelle même si j'attends vraiment de
regarder dans le détail les affectations
je les vois d'ailleurs plutôt dans la
direction de de l'industrie verte plutôt
que dans d'autres champs de la
transition mais nous le regardons et
nous vous proposerons des aménagements
pour venir parce que si nous voulons
tenir la trajectoire Pise animafouze
7 milliards signifie que les
collectivités devraient en mettre 14 et
monsieur le ministre je ne vois pas
comment les collectivités pourront
mettre 14 sur cazena les 220 millions de
hausse de la DGF ça n'est pas une c'est
une baisse en capacité d'action des
collectivités territoriales c'est quand
même pour vous que je vais devoir le
faire exprimer publiquement donc il y
aura une difficulté pour les
collectivités à prendre leur part or
elles sont un maillon essentiel de cette
transition écologique monsieur le
ministre je voulais aussi vous remercier
de prendre aujourd'hui dans ce PLF
quelques-unes des propositions que vous
aviez rejetées au PLF 2023 venant de
notre groupe je pense à la hausse de ma
prime rénove à la taxation notamment des
autoroutes au moindre avantage
défiscaliser de Airbnb et même à la
suppression de la CVA comme nos
collègues centrices nous défendions
qu'il était un peu hasardeux de le faire
vous prenez ces décisions par petites
touches et par nécessité sans changer
vos choix fondamentaux vous avez parlé
de ce triangle un peu contraint dans
lequel vous travaillez j'ajoute un côté
astrayant qui en fait un quadrilatère
c'est le refus de tout nouveau
prélèvement sur les plus aisés d'entre
nous et même sur les super profits même
si vous avez fini par trouver de quoi il
français par obtenir une taxation
européenne la nécessité de financer les
services publics et la transition
écologique demande que nous trouvions de
nouvelles recettes faute de quoi ce sera
le Triangle des Bermudes dans lesquels
notre pays se perdra nous sommes
aujourd'hui à plus 1,2 degrés et nous
voyons des conséquences dramatiques
chaque été et chaque année nous nous
avançons vers une France à plus trois et
demi à plus 4 degrés personne ici ne
peut dire ce que ça sera et donc la
dette climatique mes chers collègues est
au moins aussi importante que la dette
financière et elle peut bouleverser
totalement la cohésion sociale dans
notre pays c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous invite à vraiment faire preuve
d'intelligence c'est plutôt que
d'attendre encore un an avant de prendre
un certain nombre d'amendements écoutez
attentivement les amendements qui
demandent un ISF vers pour financer
cette transition à hauteur plus
importante et puis je vous mais mes
collègues en loi de finance vous
proposeront quelques autres amendements
qui viendront enrichir le budget puisque
j'ai bien entendu monsieur Cazenave qui
n'était pas bouclé et qu'il était
simplement ouvert
merci chers collègues pour votre
dernière intervention en commission
alors Jean-Michel Arnaud
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
on cherche des recettes complémentaires
je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
entendre et j'espère intégrer dans le
des débats la proposition de notre
président Marseille
de taxer exceptionnellement les profits
exceptionnels dans des conditions qui
permettraient notamment sur la question
des carburants de pouvoir non pas faire
l'aumône auprès des grands groupes
pétroliers mais simplement de faire en
sorte que celles et ceux qui se sont
gavés durant la période dont chacun se
souvient puisse effectivement restituer
une partie de leur surprofit au-delà de
cette observation luminaire je prends
note et je vous en remercie de plusieurs
aménagements de la fiscalité du logement
en faveur du soutien à l'accession des
propriétés des ménages j'ai noté avec
attention la progression donc de 4 ans
du dispositif de prêt
le PTZ j'aimerais que vous puissiez
accepter l'idée que cela ne puisse pas
concerner que les ménages modestes des
villes qui accèdent à des logements
collectifs mais que dans les campagnes
dans les zones rurales et dans les zones
diffusent de jeunes gens puissent
bénéficier de PTZ pour l'accessoire la
propriété et le modèle encore même s'il
est évolutif reste quand même la maison
individuelle notamment dans le monde
agricole et je pense qu'il serait
important que vous acceptiez une
ouverture sur ce sujet deuxième sujet
parce qu'il faut faire rapide toujours
sur la question du logement vous avez
dit ce matin dans la presse monsieur le
ministre et je vous en remercie que vous
étiez favorable au report des
conséquences de non-location
des classes de logement
F de 2025 à 2028 est-ce que vous
pourriez devant leur présentation
nationale ici en commission nous
confirmer ce que vous avez déclaré dans
la presse ce matin et j'espère que vous
serez si vous confirmez ce propos un
avocat à l'intérieur du gouvernement
parce que je pense est une nécessité si
on ne veut pas avoir une crise majeure
du logement en fin d'année point un
sujet sur lequel nous avions l'occasion
de ce ministre le maire de discuter à
disciplin merci Jean-Michel Didier
Rambaud
merci monsieur le Président une question
qui concerne la Une de mesures phare de
ce PLF qui est la création d'un impôt
minimum pour les grandes entreprises et
les multinationales donc pour sortir
peut-être de l'ambiance un peu
rabat-joie que je sens au niveau de
cette commission
je suis tout seul souffrait de m'écouter
15 secondes merci d'accord donc rappelez
quand même qu'il s'agit qu'à du victoire
pour d'autres pays quand même depuis
2017 on peut souligner l'action de la
France au côté de l'OCDE et que ce sujet
m'ouvre une autre question c'est est-ce
que ça peut être est-ce qu'on peut
envisager une application au niveau
européen pour les particuliers deuxième
question qui concerne la TVA alors même
si le ministre cazena va bien décliné
dans son introduction toutes les mesures
à ce sujet le Sénat était quand même
particulièrement actif sur le sujet de
la lutte contre la fraude à la TVA on
sait que c'est très complexe pour le
pôle appliqué donc est-ce qu'il peut un
petit peu nous indiquer indiquer quels
sont les prochaines étapes de la lutte
contre ce type de fraude merci
merci Didier Bernard delquer
évidemment beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
mais je vais me limiter ces promis
sur la question du crédit d'impôt
industriel évidemment nous saluons cette
cette initiative simplement j'aurai une
question un peu sur les filières et y
a-t-il des ventilations de prévues j'ai
vu qu'il pouvait s'agir des batteries
des panneaux solaires des pompes à
chaleur voilà les filières sont-elles
définies et qu'elle peut être qu'elle
peut être la ventilation deuxième point
sur le plan ambitieux de lutte contre la
fraude quelle qu'elle soit évidemment
nous le saluons et les boutiques
consacrer les moyens nécessaires
avez-vous fait une évaluation des
recettes qui pourraient générer par par
ce plan sur la question des niches
fiscales il y a plusieurs dizaines de
niches fiscales qui arrivent à échéance
en fin d'année
qu'avez-vous prévu une évaluation de ces
niches fiscales pour examiner la
nécessité ou pas l'opportunité ou pas de
de les reconduire et pour pour terminer
et pas être long évidemment je m'associe
à ce qui a été dit par mes collègues
Michel canvet notamment Jean-Michel
Arnaud sur la question on a déjà eu
l'occasion d'en parler dans les
dialogues de Bercy monsieur le ministre
la question du prêt à taux zéro il faut
pas que le recentrage se passe au
détriment des zones rurales et je me
méfie beaucoup mais joyeux l'occasion de
vous le dire de la définition des zones
tendues et non tendues c'est pas parce
qu'une zone est non tendue que on doit
pas priver des jeunes d'accéder à leur
première propriété en quelque sorte
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible et
plus important qu'il n'y paraît à
première vue donc je vous demande
vraiment de regarder cela avec beaucoup
de
bienveillance et d'esprit de
concertation avec les sénateurs merci
merci Bernard albéric de Montgolfier
c'est d'abord une invitation pour partir
pour vous monsieur le nouveau ministre
des comptes publics une invitation à
lire et à écouter le Sénat à la veille
du PLF si vous aviez écouté le Sénat sur
la hausse des taxes sur le ticp nous
n'aurions pas eu les gilets jaunes c'est
clair si vous aviez écouté le Sénat nous
aurions depuis 7 ans déjà la taxation
solidaire des plateformes donc tout ce
que vous nous dites aujourd'hui nous
l'avons proposé chaque année donc
écoutez un petit peu le Sénat la veille
de ce PLF et maintenant simplement une
question êtes-vous prêt à nous
communiquer la vie du Conseil d'État sur
le projet loi de finances et si ce n'est
pas le cas il y a une raison voulez-vous
cacher quelque chose merci beaucoup
merci Albéric Thierry Cozic
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le PLF là que vous
nous présentez et ressemble si vous me
permettez un vertigineux exercices
d'équilibrisme dans le trilemme auquel
vous souhaitez faire face me semble
antinomique
cet exercice il chute devant la
nécessité affichée pas d'engager
premièrement la transition écologique
deuxièmement tout en maintenant la
cohésion sociale enfin en mettant en
place des politiques d'austérité
budgétaires en bref ce que vous nous
proposez c'est pas de hausse d'impôts
une volonté de verdir l'économie mais
peu de choses pour le pouvoir d'achat
voilà comment synthétiquement je perçois
ce budget tout d'abord revenons sur
votre volonté je vous cite d'investir
massivement dans la transition
écologique
ils ont le clairement
son nouvelle recette notamment fiscale
et en comptant trop sur des baisses de
dépenses publiques notamment sociales ou
d'éducation
le programme que vous nous proposez
ressemble fort à un triangle
d'incompatibilité
je vous le rappelle comme l'a fait mon
collègue broyé c'est que pour faire face
à nos engagements de réduction de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
horizon 2030 les besoins de financement
sont conséquents selon le rapport
pisanime à fou le financement de la
transition climatique représenterait un
surcroît d'investissement de l'ordre de
2,3% du PIB par an et en France ce qui
représente environ 66 milliards d'euros
or nous en sommes très loin
Ménès France disait gouverner c'est
choisi et choisir c'est aussi renoncer
en choisissant de pas mettre les moyens
nécessaires dans la transition
écologique ou renoncer à la réalisation
des engagements que vous êtes fixés
vous-même sur le ministre délégué vous
déclariez récemment que nous avons deux
dettes l'une budgétaire l'autre
écologique à la défaveur des choix que
vous faites pour ce PLF il semblerait
que la première conditionne la seconde
pourtant je pense que il y a des
solutions existent vous le savez tout au
long des débats le groupe socialiste
fera un certain nombre de propositions
et notamment
l'isfaire mais aussi la proposition de
renforcer les mesures progressivité de
l'impôt et notamment l'idée selon
laquelle ceux qui ont la chance de
bénéficier de meilleures situations
doivent contribuer davantage et donc ma
question est assez simple messieurs les
ministres c'est est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à soutenir ces mesures
de bon sens qui permettraient à la fois
de combler ses dettes écologique
et budgétaire tout en faisant preuve me
semble-t-il de justice sociale merci
merci
Thierry Stéphane
la vision du calendrier dans lequel nous
sommes nous sommes engagés sur bien des
sujets dont la trajectoire est sans
doute nécessaire mais dont le rythme est
peut-être pas soutenable aujourd'hui
deuxième point sur la question des
collectivités territoriales je veux pas
revenir sur les sujets de DGF de FCTVA
qui ont déjà été évoqués ou on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir dans les débats
mais peut-être sur une approche un peu
plus large de confiance à faire aux
collectivités territoriales puisque j'ai
entendu aussi le ministre des comptes
publics dire que nos coûts de structure
sont conséquents et donc moi j'ai des
propositions à vous faire il suffirait
de supprimer ou de limiter un certain
nombre de d'agences de l'État et de
faire confiance aux collectivités
territoriales pour sans doute faire
maigrir notre dépense publique globale
de même qu'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs de l'État et je suis de ce
point de vue là surpris de voir que vous
proposiez une augmentation des postes
dans les opérateurs de l'État troisième
point pour prolonger les effectivement
sur la mobilité sur lesquels nous avions
commis plusieurs plusieurs rapports dans
notamment une mission d'information de
la commission des finances au-delà de ce
qui a déjà pu être évoqué moi j'ai une
question spécifique sur les RER
métropolitains qu'on nous annonce avec
des crédits qui sont affichés
aujourd'hui vous avez rappelé à 700
millions d'euros alors que on avait eu
une information au printemps que
l'enveloppe dans les CPER était à 800
millions d'euros et que par ailleurs on
sait que globalement ces projets
s'élèvent à 15 à 20 milliards d'euros
pour répondre à l'ensemble des besoins
des très RER métropolitains aujourd'hui
identifiés donc là aussi comme d'autres
collègues l'ont rappelé on ne voit pas
bien comment cela pourrait être
soutenable pour les collectivités s'il
n'y a pas une ingénierie financière qui
qui est mobilisé comme on a pu faire
certaines propositions au-delà des
budgets de l'État qui semble bien
réduits et où il y a un écart là aussi
entre les annonces et les crédits
affichés merci
merci Stéphane
Frédéric Espagne merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Maire dans le milieu parisien vous
avez
annoncé la suppression de l'abattement
de 71% pour les meublés classés de
tourisme dans les zones tendues afin de
l'aligner sur celui des meublés à 50%
comptez-vous également réviser les
plafonds très hauts de ce régime
actuellement fixé à
188700 euros pour les classer et 77000
pour les autres meublés donc comparatif
et en mémoire le régime bénéficiant aux
loueur du logement nu de longue durée et
permet un abattement de 30% à peu près
jusqu'à 15000 euros si je me trompe pas
je reste donc par il reste donc
particulièrement désavantageux pour ses
logements qui sont par ailleurs mon
inventables à la nuitée vous savez à
quel point ce sujet est sensible dans
territoire des Pyrénées-Atlantiques et
notamment au Pays Basque vous venez se
connaissez bien deuxième sujet qui
m'importe ainsi qu'à Bernadette roux
puisque nous avons rédigé deux rapports
un au Sénat et un sous l'autorité de
Jean Castex sur la préservation des
zones de revitalisation rurales nous
avons notamment préconisé la création
d'un dispositif complémentaire les adrèr
ent plus destinales raditalisation des
communes avec bonification des SR
exonération fiscale pour entreprise mais
aussi secteur médical et aide à la
personne notamment les EHPAD comme cela
a été évoqué par un de mes collègues
tout à l'heure je voudrais vous
interroger sur l'automaticité de ces
aides d'exonération fiscale notamment
sur les entreprises et les professions
libérales dans un premier temps et les
aides dessinées aux collectivités qui
sont aujourd'hui très attendues
notamment par les communes quelles sont
les mesures donc envisagées dans ce PLF
pour les adrr s'il vous plaît merci
merci Frédéric Charles Gonnet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que les relations avec les
collectivités locales ne sont pas très
bonnes
et vous avez pourtant cette année mis en
œuvre le Haut Conseil des finances
locales alors je veux croire de mon côté
que ça peut résulter des échanges des
pistolaires que nous avons pu avoir et
je trouve cela intéressant et je m'en
réjouis cependant on voit dès maintenant
quelque part c'est encore un peu court
puisque le cadre n'est pas défini et on
a déjà des gens qui se disent on n'a pas
été invités et ça n'est pas un cadre qui
pour l'instant est fixé et je crois que
pour que ça fonctionne il faudrait le
faire et sur un second plan je crois que
si on veut que ça fonctionne aussi il
faut que la confiance il soit et je vais
prendre un exemple d'hier puisqu'on
était au CFA elle qui pourrait être un
début de structure qui ressemble on a eu
un problème parce qu'on avait par
exemple le décret sur la répartition de
la cbae a voté enfin pour lequel on
devait donner un avis et effectivement
les ministres nous ont bien développé la
progression qu'il y avait à voir au
niveau de la TVA qui a les remplacer et
les services qui étaient là ensuite nous
ont bien expliqué
le montant de TVA qu'on avait percevoir
mais lorsqu'il s'est agit de poser la
question de savoir ce qui n'était advenu
des 650 à 700 millions qui avaient été
distrait l'année dernière enfin cette
année pour
je veux dire la finance verte et les
départements on a pu trouver aucune
explication et en fait le débat s'est
arrêté uniquement sur ce comme vous le
dites si bien monsieur le ministre se
renvoie de la balle du matin midi et
soir au lieu de discuter du fond du
sujet parce que on peut très bien
admettre que le gouvernement garde cette
poire pour la soif pour des temps
meilleurs et c'est de regarder mais je
pense que si on veut évoluer dans ce
domaine et du fonctionnement d'un au
Conseil des finances locales il faut
qu'on parle vrai et que on met les
choses sur la table et qu'on passe pas
son temps dans des chicayas alors mais
c'était un valeurs testamentaire puisque
voilà
merci Charles
Jean-Baptiste blanc conclura la série
des questions
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre dans un entretien parisien vous
avez proposé de réviser le barème du
prêt à taux zéro pour mieux l'ouvrir aux
jeunes ménages et de créer un prêt à
tout bonifier or le texte du projet de
loi de finance s'est déposé ce matin ne
semble pas contenir ses mesures qui
réduit au contraire la portée du prêt à
taux zéro en limitant un certain zones
pour les logements neufs comptez-vous
introduire
vos propositions par voie d'amendement
cette question fait écho celle de
Jean-Michel Arnaud sur le finalement le
zan sa fiscalité nous ferons des
propositions dans les vœux prochaines
semaines à travers la commission des
finances fait aussi à l'avenir du modèle
pavillonnaire pavillonnaire en milieu
rural ma deuxième question c'est
question qui a très l'article 17 qui
propose de limiter dans le temps
au-dessus primer 21 dépenses fiscales
dont 12 concernant le logement s'agit-il
seulement de modifications techniques et
quelle est votre réflexion sur la
nécessaire réorientation de ces dépenses
fiscales vers la transition écologique
et la réduction de l'artif
dans le logement urbanisme et enfin mais
je vais encore plus vite ça a été évoqué
à plusieurs reprises que pouvez-vous
nous dire concernant la réforme de la
fiscalité des locations meublées je vous
remercie merci Jean-Baptiste
monsieur le ministre il ne vous reste
plus qu'à répondre à ces quelques
questions
merci je vois que chaque sénateur
scrupuleusement respecté la règle fixée
par le président d'une
d'un thème par question
donc nous allons répondre et vers 21h30
nous l'avons la séance au moment où on
pourra discussion la loi de
programmation de finance publique à
l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez vu que tout change pour que
rien ne change
alors Michel
le report de la CVE dont axe entre vous
l'ont dit je pense qu'il est sage
effectivement quand la situation des
finances publiques est tendue d'étaler
la baisse la CVAE même si je suis
convaincu que la baisse des impôts de
production d'une nécessité absolue que
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus efficace pour
la l'industrialisation et
personnellement je vous le dis le plus
tôt nous pourrons supprimer totalement
la CVAE le mieux ce sera pour
l'industrie française et pour la
l'industrialisation du pays qui je le
rappelle emporte avec elle que des
conséquences positives des territoires
qui tout d'un coup retrouvent l'activité
des salariés qui sont mieux payés un
niveau de qualification de productivité
qui augmente c'est donc absolument
décisif pour notre pays
sur la question des
abattements pour être très au public les
agriculteurs sur le GNR
je pense qu'il faut bien voir qu'on
parle de deux situations qui sont très
différentes
ici on élargit et même trois situations
très différentes si on élargit aussi aux
transporteur le niveau des assises sur
le gazole en France et de 60,75 centimes
d'euros par litre de carburant
pour les agriculteur c'est beaucoup plus
faible puisque c'est 3,89 centimes donc
c'est vraiment très très bas c'est le
niveau le plus bas qui existe en Europe
pour être au public on part d'un peu
plus haut
et pour les transporteurs on parle d'ACO
puisqu'on parle de 42 centimes par litre
de carburant ce qui fait qu'ils sont eux
au dessus la moyenne européenne donc du
coup après 6 mois de discussion et je
vais entrer un petit peu dans les tests
je pense que c'est un modèle de
discussion qu'on doit retenir en matière
de transition écologique pour trouver
des consensus comprendre les contraintes
de chacun et apporter des réponses la
brutalité ça ne marche pas
la transition écologique par diktat ça
ne marchera pas ça ne marchera pas il
faut associer les gens trouver des
solutions et les écouter en tout cas moi
ce sera toujours ma méthode avec les
agriculteurs on a discuté pour 6 mois on
est parvenus à un accord sur une
augmentation des assises de 2,85
centimes par litre de carburant par an
jusqu'en 2003 ce qui fait qu'en 2030 les
agriculteurs garderont un avantage
fiscal très élevé quasiment 50% par
rapport au niveau d'assises sur le
gazole en France ça n'est que justice et
ça me paraît un bon accord ce travaux
publics est un peu différent parce
qu'ils sont pas exposés à la concurrence
internationale nos amis agriculteurs ils
doivent faire face à concurrence de
l'Italie de l'Espagne sur les fruits sur
les légumes de la viande sur tous les
producteurs du lait sur tous les autres
producteurs donc il me paraît légitime
que je souhaiterais au public qui un ne
sont pas exposés à concurrence
internationale deux ont eu droit c'est
une précision qu'on a prises à une
clause d'indexation des contrats sur
l'inflation eux auront une évolution un
peu plus rapide de 5,99 centimes par
litre de carburant le 6 est un accord
qu'on a trouvé qui sera là aussi lissé
dans le temps pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'un coup d'une année sur l'autre le
dernier principe fondamental c'est que
l'intégralité de ces recettes fiscales
supplémentaires ira au secteur alors il
n'y a pas d'affectation juridique parce
que n'ont pas le droit d'affecter ces
taxes mais il y a une transparence
totale pour s'assurer que l'intégralité
des recettes supplémentaires iront bien
à la transformation d'exploitation
agricoles et à la transformation des
entreprises de travaux publics ça me
paraît un principe très simple mais je
pense après six mois de discussion et
des dizaines de réunions c'est vraiment
la bonne méthode en matière de
transition écologique on impose pas on
discute il y a pas de diktat il y a des
échanges et on trouve des compromis et
si parfois ça prend un peu plus de temps
moi je préfère ça
à tous ceux qui vont faire des
déclarations pérempois le matin à la
radio en vous disant faut supprimer tous
les avantages fiscaux sur le GNR des
agriculteurs ou des entreprises de
travaux publics mais quand il se
retrouve face à des manifestations
d'agriculteurs disent on fait rien entre
faire rien et progressivement sortir des
énergies fossiles je préfère la deuxième
solution
marque MINI sur
les collectivités locales je laisserai
Thomas répondre
Hervé Morel je vais d'abord dire qu'il y
a absolument aucune autosatisfaction
d'autre part il y a simplement le rappel
des bons résultats de l'économie
française qu'on doit aux salariés aux
entrepreneurs à tous ceux qui font la
réussite de notre pays oui niveau de
dette est trop élevé simplement je
rappelle que cette dette elle est
soutenable et si elle n'était pas
soutenable et bien le spread est taux
d'intérêt qui financent la dette
publique française le spread avec
l'Allemagne les quarts de Tours avec
l'Allemagne aurait explosé or il est
stable depuis 2022 à 50 à 60 points de
base entre l'Allemagne et la France
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons
essentielles pour lesquelles il faut
tenir cette trajectoire de
désendettement
s'agissant de
la taxe aux infrastructures de transport
de longue distance cette évaluation de
600 millions d'euros de recettes pour
l'État donc 450 nous viendrons des
concessions autoroutières et 150
viendront des aéroports je rappelle
juste tous ceux qui commencent à dire
que de toute façon cela fera exploser
les prix des péages que nous nous sommes
assurés auprès du Conseil d'État que
cette décision ces infrastructures de
transport de long terme ne modifierait
pas la règle seront laquelle les tarifs
de pH sont fixés par arrêté par l'État
donc ils suivent l'inflation ils
augmenteront donc du niveau de
l'inflation mais les concessions de
routières ne pourront pas répercuter sur
les tarifs autoroutiers cette taxe
infrastructures de transport de long
terme qui ne vise qu'une seule chose
c'est financer par les activités
fossiles et brunes la transformation
économique du pays et le transport par
train
enfin le transport ferroviaire est très
vertueux du point de vue climatique mais
il coûte très cher donc si on va arriver
à financer ces infrastructures de
transport ferroviaire auxquels on croit
tous il faut bien avoir des recettes sur
des activités qui elles sont plus
polluantes
Christine Lavarde sur le coût du crédit
d'impôt industrie verte en réalité il
n'a pas changé c'est tout dépend de la
période de référence qu'on prend l'iPad
de référence et 2030 donc effectivement
ça fait un niveau plus élevé que de 2027
3,7 milliards d'euros qui devrait
rapporter 23 milliards d'euros
d'investissement ces 3,7 milliards
d'euros iront principalement aux
batteries électriques parce que chacun
voit bien que nous ouvrons énormément
d'usine de batterie électrique en France
tant mieux soit Vercors pour l'odium et
d'autres avec toutes les chaînes de
valeur qui suivent derrière une partie à
ensuite dans les montants plus modestes
pour les éoliennes pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques et en dernier lieu pour
les pompes à chaleur où nous souhaitons
évidemment monter en puissance plus
rapidement
je précise d'ailleurs pour être tout à
fait cohérent que cela de sens de donner
un crédit d'impôt sur ce type d'activité
que si de l'autre côté on favorise la
production industrielle française et
européenne et je veux dire à quel point
je suis déterminé à livrer ce combat
que ça ne sert à rien de développer
l'industrie verte pour avoir nos propres
pompes à chaleur nos propres batteries
électriques nos propres véhicules
électriques en France
si c'est pour donner ensuite des bonus à
des industries qui se trouvent en dehors
des frontières européennes donc moi je
plaide pour que comme en Chine ou comme
aux États-Unis il y est en France et
demain en Europe des aides à contenu
européen
soit un produit industriel à 60 % de
contenu européens il a le droit à l'aide
je crois il y a pas 100% de contenu
européen et il n'a pas d'aide alors je
sais que ça heurte beaucoup la doxa de
certains en Europe mais comme c'est pas
le premier combat que j'ai livré en
Europe parce que sur les gafas soit
taxation minimale sur la
taxe carbone aux frontières je pense que
ça vaut le coup de livrer ce combat et
je compte sur le soutien de la
représentation nationale car le combat
sera difficile
sur la question du bonus nous n'avons
pas encore rendu d'année arbitrage donc
je ne peux même pas vous répondre je ne
sais pas quels seront les derniers
arbitrages nous notre objectif est
d'augmenter le montant des aides à
l'achat d'un véhicule électrique pour
les classes moyennes et pour les
personnes modestes parce que ça reste
très cher et je le redis ça n'a de sens
qu'à partir du moment où nous réservons
l'attribution de ces bonus avec eux
électriques au véhicule qui sont
effectivement les plus respectueux de
l'environnement il se trouve qu'ils sont
produits en Europe tant mieux
Antoine Lefebvre je vous présente
croissant je rappelle juste qu'elles
sont en ligne avec celle du FMI et de
l'OCDE le gel du livret A je vous
confirme que le taux du livret A sera
bien gelé à 3% enfin maintenu à 3 % qui
n'est pas question c'est l'engagement
que j'ai pris de revenir sur cet
engagement d'un taux du Livret a3% ça a
été pris par un arrêté que j'ai signé
donc j'ai l'habitude de respecter ma
signature
Christian Klingert sur l'os de fiscalité
du génère je crois que j'ai répondu y
compris sur l'affectation
Daniel Breuillet dont je salue la
dernière intervention et je le remercie
pour la qualité du travail que nous
avons eu ensemble oui moi je reconnais
bien volontiers que on évolue mais si
notre débat ne sait pas évolué les
parlementaires et les ministres il ne
servirait à rien l'intérêt du débat
démocratique serein et approfondie que
nous avons au Sénat c'est effectivement
de faire bouger les lignes donc on l'a
fait sur a prime rénov augmenter la
virgule 6 milliards nous le faisons sur
la CVAE moi je connaissais ma
détermination aller vite sur ce sujet
mais on fait ce qui est possible et même
chose sur les Airbnb sur lesquels je
vais revenir nous avons effectivement
modifié la fiscalité mais une fois
encore je vous remercie de la qualité du
travail en commun et je pense que vous
pouvez vous satisfaire de ces victoires
qui sont
utile pour la collectivité
Jean-Michel
Arnaud moi je suis prêt ou nous parler
de la contribution sur la rente à frag
marginale c'est-à-dire les recettes que
nous avons récupéré sur les
profits fait par certains producteurs
énergéticiens qui sont extrêmement
élevés cette contribution sur la vente
infra marginale avec des mises en place
en 2022 une proposition européenne
confirmée en 2023 elle s'arrête à la fin
de l'année s'il est parlementaires
estiment qu'il faut maintenir cette
contribution nous avec Thomas Cazenave
nous sommes totalement ouverts à
maintenir cette contribution sur les
rentes infra marginales
s'agissons des locations de passoire
thermique
vous savez que
l'interdiction a commencé pour les
logements G+ à partir du 1er janvier
2023 moi j'appelle juste à ce que
ces mesures leur application soit
soutenable pour les gens
c'est tout donc je vois que dans les
copropriétés ça pose problème pas dire
de côté débrouillez-vous si vous avez un
propriétaire qui veut faire cette
rénovation et d'autres qui disent non
les solutions sont encore beaucoup trop
complexes on peut pas lécher les gens
sans solution donc il faut apporter une
solution est-ce que les DPE aujourd'hui
sont l'instrument le plus efficace pour
évaluer ce qui est une passoire
thermique ou pas je comprends que ça
favoriserait le chauffage au gaz plutôt
que le chauffage à l'électricité est-ce
que c'est cohérent moi je pose cette
question je suis ministre je suis aussi
citoyen
et comme citoyen j'écoute ce que me
disent les compatriotes et quand ils me
disent que c'est trop difficile trop
compliqué qu'il faut de meilleurs
accompagnements plus de clarté plus de
simplicité je leur dis qu'ils ont raison
c'est l'objet des discussions que j'ai
eu avec des lecteurs du Parisien et je
pense que ces discussions sont aussi
utiles que celles que nous avons avec la
représentation nationale au moment de la
présentation du budget enfin sur EDF
redonnez-moi la liste des communes je
veux pas vous cacher mon agacement il y
a un principe j'ai encore vu le
président de DF récemment je le vois
très régulièrement je lui ai demandé de
faire diligence pour que lorsqu'une
commune a négocier des tarifs à les
niveaux beaucoup trop élevés elle puisse
renégocier ses contrats alors j'apprends
parce que je garde les contacts avec mes
amis mère particulière euro en
particulier des zones de montagne qui me
disent généreusement ils nous ont
accordé un chèque de 50 euros par mois
c'est pas possible donc il faut que vous
me donniez la liste des communes les
contrats qui leur ont été proposés et
puis vous savez mon énergie est
inépuisable pour défendre nos
concitoyens et les communes
Didier Rambaud sur l'impôt minimum sur
les multinationales il sera mis en place
à partir de 2025 avec une recette en
2026 est-ce qu'il est possible de faire
la même chose pour les particuliers au
niveau européen oui
ça ne me pose aucune difficulté mais ça
ne peut être fait qu'au niveau européen
parce que je ne veux pas pénaliser la
France fiscalement mais en revanche on
se dise que pour les plus fortunés à un
moment donné effectivement il y a pour
toutes sortes de raisons parfaitement
légale juridiquement une baisse du
niveau d'imposition et que donc il
faudrait mettre en place un niveau
d'imposition sur le revenu minimal au
niveau européen je suis tout à fait prêt
à ouvrir cette discussion je l'ai fait
pour les plus grandes entreprises c'est
vrai que la plus grande multinationales
elles ont les moyens d'arriver à réduire
leur impôts en dessous des 15% dans la
position minimale à l'impôt société est
une réponse sur les ménages et sur nos
concitoyens je pense que c'est tout à
fait envisageable mais il ne faut le
faire qu'au niveau européen sinon on
pénalise notre P donc j'y suis prêt pour
faire simple
Bernard delcro sur les filières
concernées par le cri de la poudre
recherche crédit d'impôt pardon sur
l'industrie vert je crois avoir répondu
albéric de Montgolfier
sur la vie du Conseil d'État moi je suis
tout à fait prêt vous avez tous les
pouvoirs dans cette commission pour
avoir accès à cet avis mais je ne veux
pas le rendre public pour une raison qui
est simple c'est que les risques que
cela donne des arguments à nos
adversaires pour attaquer les
dispositifs fiscaux français sont trop
élevés mais le président la commission
des finances leur apportant général ont
tout pouvoir pour fournir ces
informations
au sénateur en s'assurant que évidemment
ces informations ne sont pas divulguées
parce que on donne des armes aux
adversaires de la fiscalité française
donc vous avez des pouvoirs pour y avoir
accès mais je ne souhaite pas le rendre
public et transparent pour ces raisons
là
Thierry cosy que je crois avoir répondu
sur les mesures pour pouvoir d'achat moi
il me semble que tout ce qui est fait en
matière de d'indexation des prestations
et tu réponds très efficace au pouvoir
d'achat sans compter la contribution sur
les carburants
Stéphane Soto d'accord avec vous sur le
rythme de la transition écologique
Frédéric Espagne une question précise
sur les abattements sur les locations
meublées classées j'insiste sur le
classé parce que sinon on va semer la
panique dans notre pays ce qui est quand
même pas l'objet de nos discussions donc
je vous confirme un abattement de 71 à
50% pour les locations de meublée
classés dit principalement Airbnb je
vous confirme que nous allons faire en
sorte que les gîtes ruraux ne soient pas
concernés sont très attention parce que
c'est une vraie inquiétude et en
troisième lieu nous alignerons
effectivement les seuils de 188700 euros
à 72600 euros pour que la mesure soit
efficace et juste et protège notamment
le Pays Basque cher à notre cœur à tous
les deux
Charles gainer sur le Conseil des
finances publiques locales je pense que
c'est un instrument qui est
extraordinairement efficace qui permet
enfin d'engager un dialogue d'égal à
égal entre l'État et les collectivités
locales moi je vous cache pas que vous
de montrant dans ma septième année de
ministre des Finances je n'en peux plus
de ces pétitions de principes et de ses
postures ou par médias interposés on dit
voilà l'état reproche aux collectivités
locales d'avoir un niveau d'épargne brut
trop élevée elle continue de locale
répond dans les ongles en écoquement
fauchés bon tout ça ne fait pas avancer
les choses donc se réunir autour de la
table discuter sérieusement c'est une
très bonne chose la composition finale
du Haut conseil n'est pas arrêté il y a
un stand d'associations de représentant
des collectivités locales qui se sont
émus de pas être autour de la table moi
je cherche l'efficacité la simplicité
donc dans un premier temps on a mis
uniquement l'AMF la RF et
l'Association des départements de France
s'il faut aussi élargir à d'autres
représentants des collectivités j'y suis
prêt il faut simplement qu'on soit pas
50 autour de la table sinon ça rend la
discussion plus difficile enfin
Jean-Baptiste blanc sur le PTZ cher
Jean-Baptiste ça ne figure pas
effectivement dans le PLF tout
simplement parce que c'est le fruit la
discussion avec les
députés qui nous a amenés à considérer
que le choix qui avait fait le
gouvernement au début qui était mon
choix donc je reconnais bien volontiers
avoir évolué là-dessus était un choix
trop fermé et que du coup la
redéfinition du barème du prêt à taux
zéro faisait qu'avec des taux plus
élevés et des apports plus faibles
finalement plus personne ne pouvant
profiter ou presque c'est pas l'objectif
donc il faut qu'on fasse évoluer le
barème pour que les classes moyennes
puissent avoir accès à ce PTZ je suis
prêt aussi à réviser des éléments du
zonage et je suis prêt à travailler
après à taux intermédiaire pour les
classes moyennes qui ne seraient pas à
zéro mais un peu en dessous des prix du
marché pour que chacun puisse disposer
d'une mise de fond au départ
merci peut-être les deux trois
précisions complémentaires pour répondre
à toutes les questions qu'ils ont été
posées de Monsieur canvé sur les EHPAD
redire qu'il y a eu un rapport
d'ailleurs
rédigé par Christine piresbonne qui a
été remise à la première ministre qui a
donné lieu à la mise en place d'un fond
d'urgence de 100 millions d'euros pour
les EHPAD et surtout l'expérimentation
dans le PLFSS
qui sera débattu en parallèle du PLF sur
de nouveaux modes de financement des
EHPAD une vraie réforme structurelle
sur la question de Monsieur Lamini sur
la l'autonomie fiscale l'autonomie
financière je vois aussi au travail du
rapporteur général Assemblée nationale
qui a essayé de regarder en ces
dernières années on voit effectivement
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
locales baisse mais que leur autonomie
financière elle augmente et par ailleurs
dans le dernier PLF nous avons ouvert un
certain nombre d'outils appréciés des
élus locaux notamment la majoration la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires nous avons étendu le
périmètre de l'application de la taxe
sur les logements vacants donc on
continue ce travail aussi pour leur
permettre leur donner des outils pour
répondre notamment aux difficultés en
matière de logement la dotation globale
de fonctionnement augmentera bien de 220
millions d'euros après une hausse
précédente
de 320 le fond vert à 2,5 au fond les
concours financiers augmentent de plus
d'un milliard d'euros entre le PLF 24 et
le PLF 23
sur monsieur Morez sur la taxe foncière
par rapport au débat entre les
associations des lieux et le président
de la République je crois que ce qu'on
peut se dire ici c'est que la taxe
foncière c'est un emploi 100% local
que on a on a souhaité la majorité ne
pas revenir sur l'évolution des bases
foncières qui avait été votée en 2016
qui sont indexées sur l'inflation ce qui
permet aux élus de faire tous les choix
qu'il souhaite soit de baisser le taux
face à l'augmentation de la base soit de
laisser le taux et d'ailleurs 85 % des
communes n'ont pas touché le taux de
taxe foncière soit de l'augmenter c'est
un débat local et c'est très bien ainsi
mais nous avons dû nous battre à
l'Assemblée face à des groupes de
position qui voulaient plafonner
l'évolution de des basses foncières et
je pense que c'est effectivement plus
respectueux la solution de nos retenu de
libre administration des collectivités
locales leur autonomie fiscale mais
encore faut-il bien reconnaître que
l'État n'y est pour rien d'une certaine
manière dans l'évolution de la taxe
foncière
Christine lavards des questions très
pointues sur le FC TVA puisqu'en effet
ce n'est pas à travers le PLF qu'on
choisit les comptes qui sont éligibles
au FCTV je vous confirme c'est le bien
le compte 212 et uniquement le compte de
112 donc n'est pas prise en compte pour
être très précis le 213 et le 214 et par
ailleurs nous ne faisons pas de
rétroactif
nous ne faisons pas de rétroactif et
c'est aussi le ministre des comptes
publics qui vous le dit en raison aussi
du coup que cela représente pour nos
finances publiques et c'est d'ailleurs
un équilibre je note quand même que
toutes les associations d'élus ont salué
notre décision et connaissez bien le
périmètre et la portée de cette décision
à 250 millions d'euros qui n'est pas
rien dans les temps qui sont les nôtres
et donc dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques vous me dites on ne
retrouve pas exactement parce que c'est
une chronique progressive et on arrivera
à 250 millions en 2026 par application
de mais il n'y a pas de mais c'est tout
à fait normal mais je
reprendrai je reprendrai avec vous si
vous le souhaitez des éléments plus
précis mais n'y voyez pas le moindre
doute sur notre décision de mettre en
oeuvre cet engagement qui a été pris
monsieur Breuillet sur sur la
trajectoire
faut pas comparer les 7 milliards
d'euros de transition écologique de
l'État avec la part publique du rapport
Pisani ferry bien sûr il y a les
collectivités territoriales pas de
transition écologique sans les
transition écologique donc c'est comment
n'encourage à investissement le fond
vert comment réoriente les
investissements au terme des enjeux de
la transition écologique la mobilisation
des 100 millions d'euros de la classe
des dépôts sur les enjeux climat et nous
aurons puisque c'est un amendement qui a
été voté lundi soir à l'Assemblée
nationale en commission des finances sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques nous aurons une trajectoire
pure annuelle de financement de la
transition écologique qui nous permettra
de faire la clarté sur les financements
publics privés et je crois que c'était
une attente d'un très grand nombre de
groupes politiques sur ces sujets là sur
la question de la déclinaison régionale
les ministres béchus notamment fort
déclineront les enjeux de la transition
écologique dans des coques régionales
ce qui me semble être aussi une bonne
méthode pour Monsieur Rambo qui
m'interroge sur les prochaines étapes de
lutte contre la fraude à la TVA c'est
très concret c'est notamment la question
pardonnez-moi de ce terme le
dropshipping c'est à dire ceux qui
depuis sur des sites internet importe
des produits à l'extérieur les revendre
en France sans application de la TVA
nous allons renforcer le dispositif pour
les attraper l'injonction numérique pour
déférencer les entreprises sur des
plateformes de commerce en ligne qui ne
respectent pas leurs obligations
fiscales nous allons donc pouvoir
émettre des injonctions numériques et
puis la création d'une représentation
fiscale unique pour collecter la TVA
puisque ça reste des sujets extrêmement
techniques et vous avez raison de lire
c'est parfois très difficile pour les
les agents de la DGFiP de remonter un
peu la fraude à la fraude à la TVA
monsieur delquereau nous allons à la
fois pour les dépenses fiscales et les
dépenses sociales plafonnées trois ans
en garde le principe du plafonnement et
l'échéance à 3 ans de toutes les niches
pour garantir la bonne évaluation et
vous aviez fait la proposition dialogue
de Bercy d'un travail sur le prêt à taux
zéro Bruno Le Maire vous a répondu je
voudrais dire à Monsieur de Montgolfier
que je suis à la fois très heureux
d'échanger ici au Sénat et d'ailleurs il
me semble bien si si je me trompe pas
que vous aviez fait des propositions en
matière de lutte contre la France à la
TVA dans vos travaux antérieurs et qui
se retrouvent précisément dans notre
plan froide donc vous voyez à quel point
nous essayons de nous inspirer aussi des
des travaux des travaux des deux
chambres
[Musique]
et enfin
Monsieur Sautarel très preneur des
pistes d'économie état collectivité état
agence venait participer à cette revue
de de mission pour faire des des
réformes structurelles maintenant toutes
les toutes les bonnes volontés pour ce
chantier assez colossal sont les
bienvenus je vous remercie
bien merci merci
monsieur le ministre pour pour vos
réponses à l'ensemble de ces questions
je voudrais
avant que nous nous quittions saluer
Gérard Longuet qui
[Applaudissements]
nous avons déjà salué bien sûr en séance
mais
lui dire sincèrement
qui nous a toujours bluffé par la
qualité de ces interventions sur son
sujet qui était l'éducation ou
généralement sa méthode consistait à
mettre vous savez trois mots sur un
papier et après il faisait la durée que
l'on souhaitait
Charles Gonnet qui est mon collègue et
ami bien sûr sur les relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
et Daniel brouiller qui
qui est arrivé sur travailler emploi et
c'est marrant il est resté à peine
puisqu'il est arrivé dans le cadre d'un
remplacement d'une sénatrice qui partait
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est assez
amusant vous savez ces garçons qui ont
été élus pendant très longtemps qui ont
été à la retraite puis qui tout d'un
coup du fait de remplacement se retrouve
à revenir au Parlement et deux heures
après être rentré en commission se
trouve comme s'ils étaient là depuis 6
ans voilà un vrai savoir-faire merci
Daniel également merci à tous les trois
pour ceux que vous avez apporté à cette
commission merci à tous